[Music]
there's some outrage
in hong kong right now is china taking
that [ __ ]
it's uh well it's not about that well
maybe there's something about that but
what i'm talking about is not about that
i pictured china grabbing hong kong and
joe says it's taking that [ __ ] no
it's almost like saying
that's right china so
hong kong has asked pet shops and owners
to hand over close to 2 000 hamsters for
culling by authorities culling what's
that killing them
what they're going to kill them for what
they don't like though after 11 of the
small rodents tested positive for the
chrono virus in a pet shop they got a
lot
we already got this [ __ ] from pangolins
or bats
who knows this guy's been watching south
park what if that strain when you when
you cough from the hamstrings
and people go
you go to edinburgh and stuff in their
tree
like why am i doing this now
so the the territories also suspended
the import of small animals and
authorities announced this decision on
tuesday just after the city's health
experts found two groups of hamsters
which originated in the netherlands and
arrived in hong kong on december 22 and
january 7 to be high risk for carrying
the novel coronavirus hamsters turned
over by pet owners will be killed to cut
the transmission chain
i mean just keep them in their little
thing right it's like quarantine i had
no idea
amsterdam had a [ __ ] hamster factory
that's why it's called hamster amsterdam
[ __ ] 10 out of 10. y'all come on
amsterdam it's for you hold on dude
evidence shows that the hamsters are
infected with the covenant 19 virus and
it is
impossible to quarantine and observe
each of them and their incubation period
could be long can they just vaccinate
the [ __ ] the hamsters i don't
know i mean they could catch it
i think they really think it's just
easier to [ __ ] exterminate all
hamsters in the country [ __ ] dude which
is why people are protesting i still
think i just keep them in their cage
yeah
let them quarantine and [ __ ] the [ __ ] is
wrong with them two weeks five days now
yeah like what do you think they're
doing going to the hamster park and then
spreading it
they're going to hamster damn dude
if hamster dave is lost then we've lost
everything having super spreader parties
how did they even test the hamsters to
know that they got cobid like was it
during like when they came to the hong
kong and then the border patrol was like
giving them mini pcr tests
i love that let's talk let's have a
little mini tsa for all the hamsters
maybe the hamptons ate their favorite
food and like
can't taste it
and they weren't eating they're like
something's up with them
they stopped running in the circle
because their lungs were getting
impacted
their teeth are chattering because
they're cold they're wearing masks
they're self-isolated from each other
that's really cute the u.s center for
disease control and prevention called
the risk of animals spreading the virus
to be to people low but noted that it
can spread from people to animals during
close contact i mean that's how it
happened with bats right well the
exception appears to be minx with cases
of humans being affected by them and in
2020 denmark called some 17 million
commercially raised minks after they
were found to be at risk of carrying the
coronavirus
yeah that was like mink ginosa yeah wait
denmark killed 17 17 million
millions that's for the mink coat
industry bro that's a cover-up wait yeah
yeah how do you even find that many
minks the the coat industry the fur
industry oh they're commercially raised
wait so white people kill more animals
than asians do
yeah see flip the narrative 17 million
people that's crazy talk on a brother
that's a genocide white people killed
more than asians yeah because the
chinese fools how many they want to kill
they only kill like one or two for food
2 000 hamsters they just want to eat
wild stuff but you know yeah they only
wanted to eat a few bats come on dude
like live a little i know right and
white people out here like massacring
whole entire [ __ ] population is like
come on while they're silent but
later the danish government later
admitted that the minks were improperly
killed and buried and the commission has
been established to look into the case
they barely didn't even do it right
yeah they didn't do it right whoa in
cramped hong kong though hamsters have
been popular as cute and low maintenance
pets and the city like mainland china is
holding firm to a policy of zero covid
imposing extreme 21 day quarantine
requirements on anyone arriving from
overseas 21
the territory was able to maintain zero
local infections for weeks until
december when two flight attendants
returning from the u.s who were infected
with the highly transmissible omicron
variant
went out into the community wow
and then last week a 23 year old woman
working at a pet shop called little boss
in hong kong's causeway bay was found to
be infected with the delta variant which
has been rare in the city at the same
time several hamsters in the pet shop
also tested positive for the coronavirus
because she sneezed on what if she gave
it to them she [ __ ] gave the lizard
she's like she's touching all the
animals i know health officials in hong
kong are investigating this as a
possible case of animal to human
transmission because two other human
infections one confirmed in one
preliminary have been linked to the pet
store damn now the human gave it to the
animals that sounds like a yeah like she
went and did like a party
came back she's all petting them i know
she's rubbing noses with all the [ __ ]
hamsters no you're so cute just killing
them
the house was like oh [ __ ] wear masks
she's like six feet yeah
no
six vertical feet come on man
dude because remember there were all the
animals in the zoos getting kobe like
chimpanzees how did they get affected
was it through like the zookeepers
handlers and stuff giving them food and
[ __ ] yeah they're doing the same thing
with all the tigers helping visuals
you need to realize that the hamsters
which have already gotten infected are
excreting the virus they can affect
other animals other hamsters and human
beings we have to protect public health
and we have no choice this is what
happens when you study too much yeah you
know too much [ __ ] you know because now
you're like trying to fix a problem
too much research yo yeah dude you just
you just drive right yeah people tell
you to get [ __ ] oil changes you just
keep driving so it doesn't drive no more
and then you fix it once it breaks down
yeah until the [ __ ] tires fall off or
it starts smoking and you're like oh
[ __ ] same thing with science
you just gotta be like i don't know i'm
trying to go back and get oil change
every five thousand miles
hit in the ass man imagine if we were
like they're like oh all these humans
got them just kill them
just get rid of it later be uh we uh
improperly killed them and buried them
so my bad
all right guys see you later that's it
nothing happens the people that were
killing them got sick too
so we gotta kill them too i know what
the [ __ ]
well with hong kong when they came for
the hamsters it proved to be the last
straw for long-suffering residents of
hong kong the city has endured and
largely complied with extreme and often
baffling pandemic rules schools and gyms
are closed restaurants must shut down at
6 pm air travel from most major hubs
have been severed playgrounds are sealed
off with tape but when the government
announced the call of 2000 pet hamsters
a line was crossed and the rodents could
carry the coronavirus but people are
pissed off so resistance groups have
assembled on telegram messaging app to
share updates drawing on methods used in
anti-government protests and now they
are smuggling and hiding hamsters all
over hong kong
so aren't they spreading the virus more
maybe and if that does happen
that's going to be a sick movie in the
future that's a crazy subplot to this
whole covet stuff it's like train to
busan but like hamsters
i just want to see what this militia
group looks like and what their flag is
and do they wear like all [ __ ] black
with like little giant ass hamsters
they're just hamsters that's the reveal
their utility belts all have little
cages and nuts and [ __ ] like that snacks
yeah so this is the smackdown hong kong
is one of those cities though it's like
it sucks to quarantine in because
everything is crap yeah it's crazy it's
small it's dark like because you can't
go out it's like damn dude
that's gonna be a [ __ ] let me give you
a chilling image of the reality on the
streets of hong kong whoa
what's the background of the the guinea
pig or the hamster is like how would
they know that these people have
hamsters though imagine the moment where
they're just like breaking in doors and
stuff like that little kids like no
they're just grabbing hamsters damn yeah
how do they how do they know you don't
have to register him yeah i mean you
register them out there they knock on
every door they're like hamster checks
sorry hong kong police
they just ask you they go do you have a
hamster and if you go no
what's that wrestling over there it's
the opening scene of inglorious bastards
you got hamsters in the [ __ ]
basements and [ __ ]
it's just like i'm going to speak
english now okay that scene is [ __ ]
he's like do you have hamsters under the
floor yeah point to other hamsters can i
have some milk please
do you know what they call me
can i have a hamster yes i mean no i
mean
i don't have any hamsters what are you
talking about they're just trying to do
stupid mind games they're just like is
it
over here
and they start shooting the floor oh
man
these poor hamsters go
[Music]
you